i'm sure you're hearing that from every
person you're talking to
how awesome the movie is it must be very
tough it's
so exciting i have to say it's so good
because you generally
know when someone especially like
interviews and stuff like that you know
journalists and it's really exciting
when you see someone
you see in their eyes that they're
genuinely like excited about it
oh the movie is fantastic um
awesome yeah uh i the thing i love about
this movie the most is that
james gunn script because it all starts
on the page and what i love about it is
that
every scene takes a left turn you're not
expecting
um for both of you can you talk about
what you are excited for fans to see and
what you loved about
james's script when i read the script
for the first time i was really excited
exactly of what you said like you don't
expect the next page
and that's really exciting because at
every page it's a new excitement
but as a comic book fan as a fan of dc
and this world i think it's really cool
that it's a
it's a hero superhero film but
it's so grounded in kind of reality and
the insanity of it and the characters
are so
weird and insane in a great way that
there's a lot of comedy in it
and i think having a superhero film with
a lot of comedy and soul
and and and greediness and blood it's so
exciting it's so exciting to be able to
go
to take that turn for a superhero film
that i'm
i was i was blown away i knew when i saw
james gunn is directing
suicide squad i knew it was going to be
really special
ring the script like you said it was
even more because
it was the reality of what i imagined at
least
hit it on the head like the fact that
it's a superhero movie but it has a lot
of depth
as well and the characters actually go
deeper in this movie and um you know a
lot of people ripped it off when they
announced that they were going to
suicide the squad again so i'm really
happy that the reaction of people who
have watched it so far
have seen that james gunn as i pulled it
and just hit it at the clock you know
i think he's when i watched it i
couldn't believe the pacing i actually
like really enjoyed the painting of the
movie it just kind of builds and builds
and builds
and you know there's no lagging moments
and each character has their own art and
stuff so it's
yeah they're in for over two hours of
pure entertainment
yeah that's another thing i i watched in
imax yesterday and there's like no
wasted scene
you know it's like every scene builds
you know and i'm so glad you watched on
imax because we
shot like james wanted to shoot in imac
so it's it's really
it's really the best way to see the film
i mean if you can go to theaters that's
the best way to see it because he
envisioned for that and then i'm glad
that the theaters are open now
when i watched it the screen in because
i watched it in like a secret place in
warner brothers
and was that i didn't watch it on imax
because it was so big the movie's so big
but i was like damn i really wanted the
first time to be just
coming at me so overwhelming i love
learning about the behind the scenes of
the making of a movie things that you
don't read in the press notes you don't
hear about
for each of you what do you think might
surprise people to learn about the
making of the suicide squad
the beach is man-made and the jungle
yeah and the jungle
on the beach it's all man-made so it's
all in studio
which is mind-blowing i remember walking
that student being like
i can't believe this is a studio and
also i think
the best thing and james already said
many times people already know but
it's his vision like it's his cut
straight up beginning middle and then
and i think it's so wonderful when you
get that it's so wonderful that warner
brothers did that
really for the fans and seeing james
going as a fan of comics and as a fan
of this type of world it's really
exciting that
he it's his vision from beginning middle
and end from script to page to editing
and i don't want to give any spoilers
but the king shark is actually not real
a real shot
[Laughter]
i'm blown away by the vfx on shark
because is it amazing
there's a shot in the movie where he's
looking out a window and you see the
reflection of the city
while you're also looking at him and he
looks real
it's crazy they did an amazing amazing
job
yeah and the guy that played him is a
wonderful actor yeah
stephen 100 um listen i got to stop
there
and i really mean it congrats on the
movie everyone's gonna love it
have a fantastic day thank you so much
you too have a wonderful day